hey Hanna Hey so making a DIY video to
make stuff to make my house of less
shitty do you know how I don't I was
wondering if you could help me yeah yeah
yeah sure to make a DIY video of me yeah
why not
let's do it good high five hey today
we're gonna show you how to make one
hundred and fifty dollar pillows for
around 20 bucks each throw pillows are
the easiest way to transform a couch
it's something that can tie your room
together without having to spend a ton
of money but first I gotta see what I'm
working with
well it's like check out the space yeah
actually we passed my house I've got a
couple okay
welcome to my home this is my house so I
just moved here about a month ago yeah
and I want this to be my first adult
apartment I love this place I just kind
of inherited all the shitty furniture I
think definitely couches are kind of a
bland color I can't afford a new couch
but I can't afford new pillows I want to
do this technique called shibori
it's a method of folding fabric and then
you're gonna use indigo dye you color it
I feel like with a little pop of color
because your walls are white I think
it's really gonna do a lot are these
gonna stay yeah there's samurai swords
you play with it you don't play with
them they're decorative and they're also
for fighting this is my bookshelf that's
built-in you want to show me your toys
yeah this is lando calrissian this is
Marty McFly this is a novelization of
the Rugrats Passover episode and it was
a dollar it was a dollar it's a steal
this is mr. Bacon's big adventure it's
basically Candyland with me I have all
five of these spice in my pocket spice
girl books my favorite word is
existentialism I can't say it and I'm
not quite sure what it means this kind
of reminds me of like a dangerous
children's room right now thank you
we'll focus on the pillows and then
maybe see where we can go from there but
we need to do something about this lamp
you can find it on the sidewalk for this
project what do we need
indeed I can five gallon bucket rubber
band popsicle stick clothes pins and
some heavy-duty rubber gloves it covers
more of your arm
I like your shade of pink thank you I
love the shampoo it matches your hair
and the important thing with indigo dye
is you use a hundred percent white
cotton there's just an all cotton white
case four bucks each so the pillow of
ten dollars at IKEA okay so first things
first four gallons of warm water we have
our reducing agent for both of those in
and the Indigo it's a reducing agent
that's just gonna help it adhere to the
fabric when you're dyeing something you
need a reducing agent yeah very good
oh it's awful smells like sweaty gym
socks that's why we're outside mix that
all together let it sit for a little bit
it's like a witch's cauldron
it is like potions class right let's
cover this up and set it to the side oh
that's heavy
Oh careful oh my god I spilled on myself
already are you ready to start folding
fabrics so you got a few different
folding techniques right we have so many
pillowcases and they were so inexpensive
I say we just try if you the most basic
fold is an accordion fold cause like in
it so you're gonna do one pulled over
flip it and fold it the other way and
again so from this do a square you're
gonna accordion this way okay this is
gonna be the most frustrating part of
the process making sure your folds
aren't even you boys AK over here
[ __ ] nailed it beginner's luck so
we're gonna use these wooden blocks
these wooden blocks press where you
don't want the die to see fit rubberband
these together nice and tight look how
cute they are
don't they look adorable they're like
little packages of joy it's a great
thing is you don't really know if it's
gonna be good or bad you just do it
there's so much more positive than my
normal friends so from this there's so
much you can do triangles I love
triangles we're gonna fold it in an
accordion triangle
really fancy I do do some like clothes
pins clipped around it
let's do circles this is the easiest tie
you're going to do so you're gonna find
the middle poke it up so you have this
little clump right here you're gonna
take your rubber band you can do one
large circle or a bunch of little one
and they both look really really cool
like a little ghost what do you think
his name would be Percy no too fancy
let's get to dip in so these are gonna
go in we're gonna submerge them very
slowly so the air bubbles completely out
of them as we're sticking them down and
you go you go if they're floating to the
surface a little bit you can just give a
little good spin every so often and this
is like a pair of eclipses we're gonna
keep these in from one to three minutes
we're gonna take them out hang them for
20 minutes and allow them to oxidize oh
it's so green
watch it game we're gonna squeeze it out
because you just don't want him to go
died drip it all over the place well and
look at the difference between this one
and that one it's only been out for a
few seconds but you can see the gradient
of how it oxidizes over time we will do
this twice and then wholly rinse them
out and then see what happens here so
one to three minutes out for 23p rinse
done we're gonna do for 20 minutes
it's pretty cool right yes okay so now
we are rinsing off the cases this is
like the most annoying process where
you're just like rinsing and squeezing
when it starts to run clear we're good
man you gotta really work it this is
yours oh no I think you should do it I'm
too nervous
ready yeah wow that's beautiful so we do
this with all of them now we rinse them
out and then we put this in the washer
dryer yes with like soap and everything
like okay that's it it's brightness yeah
use my elbow a teamwork all right so
it's about three weeks later why three
weeks we're busy deal with it I have
seen the pillows because I live here but
Hannah you have not you haven't invited
me over
what the heck I've been a little nervous
to see how they turn out
kind of hit and miss you never know what
you're gonna get oh also if the pillows
actually inspired me to do a little more
decorating oh my god so yeah I'm so
proud of you though thank you I think
we've talked enough on this stoop this
is not even my stoop it's a stranger's
to make yeah her sheet oh look good
[Music]
welcome oh my god did we do good like
reading a huge sign for your great the
room has so much right it's brighter
yeah and these couches don't look so
dull oh my gosh hmm the pillows helps
brighten up the room and then made me
realize what kind of carpet I should get
the carpet then you realize like what I
should put on the walls I know it sounds
silly but this one piece kind of helped
me just figure out what everything else
should look like I just can't get over
how good each of the patterns looked and
it comments a starter pack which I love
it imperfections just become details oh
my gosh so online these shibori pillows
can cost up to one hundred and fifty
dollars now it's time to find out what
did we actually spend
okay close 1548 hold on I lost my
calculator okay it over wait 14 dollars
and 11 cents a pillow confetti direct it
knowing that you can make up to fifteen
things with one batch so that price will
come down and down and shibori t-shirt
it's shrunk it's now a child thank you I
guess that's it huh
now that we've transformed the couches
and the wall you wanna keep going
there's a lot more we can do starting
with that table what's wrong with the
table
DIY difficulty out of ten three what's a
one possible stick rooms no that's way
harder the glue slips oh my god today
Sabrina the Teenage Witch game wait
can I borrow this this is so cool I've
got a choice here I am on the front dang
let's see it's not even like scratched